[Music]
welcome back to tonight's live special
dr. Anthony foul she has done more than
maybe any other American official to
promote long-term nationwide quarantines
the lock downs that are destroying our
economy foul she suggested that
handshakes should go away forever
he told Congress that reopening schools
next fall might be a bad idea but then
today fout she seemed to wobble here's
what he said in an interview with CNBC
we can't stay locked down for such a
considerable period of time that you
might do irreparable damage and have
unattended consequences including
consequences for help
Oh irreparable damage unintended
consequences it might have been nice to
hear a little bit more of that months
ago when it actually mattered back when
doctors were being kicked off of YouTube
for saying exactly the same thing
barstool sports president Dave Portnoy
noticed and had these thoughts this is
my whole point
so gee I just did a rant that like went
viral literally like last week because
you like if we open up the country it's
everyone's gonna die I'm paraphrasing
but that's like what he said now I pull
and heat on him in people like we had to
open we're gonna die if we stay inside
now he says though the wind blows and
he's like okay no no no if we can't stay
in forever it causes irreparable damage
if we stay what is it foul G pick a side
or at least say you don't know what the
talking about if nobody knows anything
then what the are we doing
Dave Portnoy has been locked indoors for
a couple of months in New York City he
just nicely good Dave so what is you so
you're sitting at home you're monitoring
this you've got a special interest
because you are quarantined yourself
what did you make of what about she said
well I mean I was taken off guard in
first of all I did escape to Nantucket
that's why I didn't have the the type of
suit in the ties to the tea port night
but you know I I thought it's taking
crazy pills for a second I really did
and listen I don't mean to pile on
kouchi
but we're making very important
decisions based on what he said
and I think it's okay to say I really
don't know guys but I get the feeling if
you ask them this question or what's one
plus one equal you're gonna get seven
different answers it's okay to say you
don't know that's kind of my point I
don't think anybody really knows the
true answers it's a moving target it's a
disease we've never met with before but
that's why I think at this point you let
people individuals make decisions for
themselves because nobody know the only
thing as I said before that we
absolutely know for certain is if you
continue the quarantine you continue to
lock down tons of people are gonna lose
their livelihoods those people should
have the choice to make decision rather
than depend on things that listen pouchy
may be the nicest guy in the world but
he said wear masks don't wear masks he
said you know the lockdown is gonna go
on indefinitely we're gonna end the
lockdown so it's just tough to really
put that much stake in what he's saying
when I just don't think he knows maybe
Trump just got him in a room and shook
him he's like today you say this so I
don't know but it's tough to take you
seriously when you literally say the
exact opposite and we're not talking
months we're talking days apart
what changed so look I think your point
about not really knowing what the truth
is is is a absolutely fair and important
one and we I've certainly been wrong on
this show a bunch of different times but
I admit it cuz I I know that people have
YouTube and they can check foul she
comes on and acts like he's always been
saying this when two days ago he was
saying the opposite shouldn't he at
least acknowledge the change absolutely
and you know any politician or anybody
in general I would much prefer somebody
first of all have no problem saying
guess what I don't know yeah I'd rather
that right but if you have a strong
opinion say it and if you're wrong then
say hey hand up I'm the first line like
break my arm when I make a mistake in
you know what American people they
appreciate that they want to know when
you're wrong I invest in a Chinese
company you probably hate deport Baba it
tanked today there was a revolution
guess what I made the wrong move you
have to just say it own up to it no
one's expecting any human being to be
perfect but when you say a very
important statement and act like it
never happened to say something
different it raises you know I was like
what is he doing I don't know that he's
doing intentionally but either take the
side or say I don't know in acknowledged
when you make a mistake
that's how you trust because right now I
don't trust what he says I don't know
how anybody could and again I don't know
it's intentional I just honestly think
this thing moves and if you go I mean
there's videos about you all through
this
he's on different sides depending on the
day depending on mood like I said the
way the wind blows and we're making
seemingly life-changing decisions for
other people based on facts that clearly
are not facts well exactly so yesterday
foul she did an interview with Julia
Roberts not the journalist but the
actress did that make you trust him more
or less I mean there's an element that
you'd want your lead doctor and pandemic
not going with a Hollywood starlet but
it doesn't you know he's got a
believable face I I listen if you know
him in front of me and I didn't know all
the mismatched stuff I'd be like I trust
him he looks smart but I'm paying
attention to the words I wouldn't say
talking Julia Roberts looks I like
pretty woman as much as the next guy so
I'm not gonna hold that against them I
totally agree about the way he looks
when I see foul Qi on TV with the sound
off I think I believe that guy and he
does come off as a nice person we've
interviewed him on the show it's nothing
personal
but I think people have listened so long
because he look like he looks like the
guy you would listen to I very smart he
salute looks like an expert in to be
honest yet every single you know
question or speech he sounds like an
expert like if they're all one offs
I beg okay I'll listen and I'll believe
but now they're fit enough footage
everyone's walked in siding they're
hanging on what he says like when he
goes in from the Senate and says if we
open too quickly there's gonna be mass
damage and death those are heavy heavy
words - then go say the exact opposite
in a week later he's it's almost the
gravity of what he says in the moment
it's almost like he's losing a he's
gonna be very careful with the words
because again what he says I feel like
is what a lot of states are basing
they're reopening on and it changes so
what information what model it so it's
always a moving target and what we got
to remember is again I don't think
anyone really knows the answer
but it's tough then to tell a business
owner hey you're gonna lose your
business because what about she said and
the guys like well at what point when
when of what what yardstick are we using
or what day are we using what pouch she
said I I think at this point I trust
Julia Roberts one Dave Portnoy great
DC's he's very believable she's a very
believable American that's the team port
at least and for something and then
admit when you're wrong but Julia
Roberts very very believable very good
to see me